[Music]
kardashians in Costa Rica the
kardashian-jenner squad headed south to
Paradise for their annual family
vacation but per usual the drama
followed it's pretty obvious that the
girls knows something's up I already
felt like under fire not long after Kim
found a girl hiding in Scotts hotel room
in Dubai the father of three repeated
the same behavior and invited another
lady friend on the family getaway we're
here to just be a family and I don't
understand why he would even think to
invite somebody it's hurtful and
disrespectful
Scott's move comes as a bit of a
surprise after seeing the former flame
spend quality time together as a family
they were even affectionate with one
another but in true Kardashian fashion
the sisters confronted Scott at a family
dinner this is just the most Awkward
dinner he said I'm doing what I have to
I think what we're wondering is if you
have a girl here and wife
and in a teaser for next week things get
even more heated there's a level of
respect and appropriateness if you need
to get your wet that badly and you get
your sweat